tonight a special edition of brian ross
investigates
meet the veteran mississippi reporter
still on the case
exposing how gangs rule the state's
prisons even
after promised reforms back at it again
brian
um yeah they they're they're not happy
with a lot of silence
uh most of this time you know they've
kind of just circled the wagons
in south carolina taking on local
sheriffs and prosecutors
public money for baseball game tickets
trips to the galapagos islands
flying first class all the way
investigative reporting
that helped send a powerful prosecutor
to prison
no reaction to the taxpayers
absolutely nothing plus the internet
wins
teaching the country's leading
investigative journalists a thing or two
i've done about trainings for about 2
000 journalists in the last four months
new york times washington post abc cbs
associated press basically teaching them
the tricks of the trade
and remembering the man who made sure
reporters had the resources
to cover the plight of america's poor in
appalachia
where tom galloway grew up and never
forgot
tom really dedicated his entire career
to trying to
help those people who are underserved
telling their story became part of that
work
from the law and crime network studios
in new york city's
herald square this is a special edition
of brian ross investigates good evening
and welcome to a special encore edition
of brian ross investigates
highlighting our series of shout outs
recognizing some of the outstanding
local
investigative reporting that often
doesn't get the attention it deserves
and we start with the work of a veteran
reporter who has devoted his life
to exposing outrageous violations of
human rights
in his home state of mississippi it all
started
with a cell phone call from an inmate
back in 2013
hey i want to tell you about all the
corruption that's going on inside the
prison
and all these beatings and various
things that are happening
and nothing's being done about them it
was a call to action for investigative
journalist jerry mitchell six years ago
leading to a damning expose in the
clarion ledger in jackson mississippi
and a series of supposed reforms in the
state prison system
and all of a sudden i keep getting
reports of things getting worse
so once again mitchell is on the case
now turning up evidence
of how the understaffed prisons are
really being run by criminal gangs
in lockdown we joined the mississippi
center for investigative reporting
and pro-publica to investigate critical
understaffing this video obtained by the
marshall project
shows what officials call a gang ordered
murder on an inmate
seen running from his attackers trying
to get away trapped in a shower cell
stabbed 10 times and left for dead
one of four gang killings inside this
prison alone
it's a horrible situation and basically
even
top prison officials have admitted that
the gangs are in charge of these prisons
so we've uncovered
all these things of how gangs control
how prisons
operate how did it come to be that the
gangs
not the warden and the guards run the
prison
well if you don't have enough officers
like if at night if all you have is a
tower officer and really know what they
call floor walkers
um i mean we exposed in south
mississippi correctional institution
time after time this happened so as a
journalist this is a real challenge
because you can't be inside
there exactly you have to rely on them
talking about you
and can you trust their accounts how do
you verify and double check what i'll
tell you
that's a great well you you piece it
together
you use inmates you use
reports you use incident reports and
things like that
use correctional officers who work there
really to kind of get a picture i love
i love reporting on hidden worlds and
this is like one of them
it's become a big issue in mississippi
this cell phone video surfaced last week
and once again mitchell's investigative
reporting is making waves in mississippi
in part of the prison on fire
investigate tv have uncovered
alarming staff shortages at prisons
across the country
there is simply not enough manpower in
place to keep tabs on the more than 3
000 inmates at our house there back at
it again
brian um yeah they they're they're not
happy with a lot of silence
uh most of this time you know they've
kind of just circled the wagons
but prison officials have acknowledged
the problem when you don't have the
appropriate level of staff
you know safety is a concern before his
new series on prison expose
mitchell made big news when he obtained
this photograph
of three mississippi college students
posing with guns
in front of the bullet-ridden sign
commemorating the death
of emmett till a fourteen-year-old
african-american
who was lynched in 1955 after being
accused of the rape
of a white woman i had a friend of mine
say
this looks like a trophy shot so instead
of a you know a 10-point buck they're
standing in front of the emmett till
sign you know
it's just very disturbing the three
students
all members of an ole miss fraternity
were suspended
another black eye for mitchell's home
state
as a reporter you don't you know your
your obligation
is not to protect somebody's reputation
it
requires us to tell the truth so you're
really filling
a huge gap in local investigative
journalism
we really feel we are brian it's an
important thing i i
i know you feel i feel you know
investigative reporting
is so key it's
so important to our democracy to to make
it work right we have to know
citizens have to have knowledge of
what's really going on
it is that very same dedication that has
led reporter tony bartlemy in south
carolina
to hold accountable the very people who
are supposed to be
the guardians of justice local sheriffs
and prosecutors
no reaction to the taxpayers
absolutely nothing it was a tip to a
local investigative reporter
that led this summer to prison time for
powerful south carolina prosecutor
dan johnson reporter tony bartomy of the
post and courier in charleston south
carolina
found the evidence he needed for his
story on the prosecutor
in johnson's own expense reports nobody
had looked at him yet nobody had sifted
through them
so i got a hold of them started looking
through them and a bunch of things just
immediately popped out including a 173
uber ride in minneapolis where bartlemy
used to live
i thought you know i bet you went to
prince's house
on the public's dime and lo and behold
that's exactly what he did
during that trip he also to spent uh
money on a major league baseball game
the twins and from there we started
looking into other things like trips to
the galapagos islands
first class playing trips to all over
the country and things like that
bartlemay who is the senior reporter on
the poston couriers investigative team
says they decided to expand their probe
into all official expense reports
so we thought what are other islands of
government in south carolina that
kind of exist on their own without much
scrutiny and sheriffs immediately
came to mind and so we basically we
sought every spending record we could
get from every county in the state all
46
counties suspended greenville county
sheriff will lewis
is facing more charges tonight among
those highlighted by barlemy was sheriff
will lewis of greenville county
now facing criminal charges that he was
using public money
to carry on a sexual relationship with
an employee who has now claimed
she was raped he has denied the charges
and her claims
her allegations that basically forced
her to have sex
forced her to do other things in
and use that fear of termination losing
her job
as a as a cudgel next was the sheriff of
florence county
people who live in the area are speaking
out after the man they elected sheriff
kenny boone was arrested and charged
with embezzlement and misconduct in
office
sheriff kenny boone is also now facing
state charges
as a result of bartlemy's reporting he
too has pleaded
not guilty again it was all these these
these sort of questionable expenses for
personal gain the most serious charges
came
following bartleby's story on sheriff
alex underwood
underwood had a had a pattern of
misbehavior
ranging from assaults he'd assaulted a
couple of fire chiefs at a traffic stop
and also a man was live streaming a
traffic wreck as the man was streaming
his video on facebook
sheriff underwood is seen approaching
him and can be heard
challenging him
i got somebody's arm and james right
here
there was a scuffle essentially
underwood and his deputies
threw the guy in jail cooked up a bunch
of bogus charges
and then tried to cover up when the fbi
began to investigate
sheriff underwood is now under federal
indictment he has pleaded not guilty to
the charges
when we put it all together we produced
uh you know
a very large package of stories
that really kind of captured the scope
and significance
of and history of why sheriffs have
gotten into trouble
bartleby says his editors know such
investigative reporting takes time
and money but that they have decided it
is the only way
local newspapers can survive in the past
few years we've
analyzed the data and we've found that
people are more likely to subscribe to
stories that are done
with depth and quality
we found that the sheriff's story for
instance generated the most
subscriptions of any story last year
or earlier this year on a local level
it's really the only way we'll be able
to survive and
we are finding that investigative
journalism though it's expensive
is what keeps people reading on a
personal note i was surprised to learn
that tony bartlemy
was the son of the late joe bartomy an
nbc news executive who was one of my
early bosses and mentors nice to see the
tradition of hard-hitting journalism
continuing in that family up next a
shout out for someone who has proven to
be so good at what he does
that now major news organizations and
networks want him to teach their
reporters how to do
what he does
back now with our special encore edition
for local journalists whose work
deserves our recognition
and appreciation including someone who's
skilled at digging and investigating
is so incredible major news
organizations and networks
are hiring him to teach their reporters
how to do it
it was in the middle of a blizzard in
washington d.c
when seamus hughes scored one of his
many big scoops this year
it was a snowy day my kids were playing
the front yard they were building a
snowman and i
needed a break from cleaning off the car
and for fun
hughes is the kind of person who likes
to look at a website called pacer
that records the activities of federal
criminal courts
around the country documents have been
posted on pacer in maryland that day
and came across it what he came across
was the indictment of a member of the
u.s coast guard
who had purchased a huge quantity of
weapons and authorities say
was about to use them to carry out a
mass murder
we just tweeted it out and then by the
time the snowman was was done we had
about ten thousand retweets
on it it was a huge story that made
headlines across the country
investigators say he was planning a
major attack on innocent civilians they
say they found at least
15 guns and 1 000 rounds of ammunition
prosecutors are calling him a domestic
terrorist a story that might have gone
unnoticed by other journalists
but for seamus hughes and he used the
same sleuthing technique to break the
story of the government's indictment
of wikileaks founder julian assange i
was looking at a case
in virginia of uh of a guy who was
supporting terrorism
and the prosecutor in that case
accidentally filed
information related to julian assange so
entirely serendipitous
entirely serendipitous references to
wikileaks founder julian assange
in an unsealed court filing suggesting
he might be criminally
charged wikileaks founder julian assange
has been charged
under seal another major story for which
the country's leading journalists owed
hughes a giant thank you
i think there's there's two things going
on right one is um
a lack of training when it comes to open
source collection
and looking at court records and the
other thing is chasing the news of the
day
um you know the late the latest
presidential tweet will get you more
clicks than
a deep dive in a coast guard um
individual who was thinking about
joining
neo-nazism and so
that's you go in areas where nobody else
is really uh farming
yeah i think that's that's fair um
there's no reforming and to be fair
we're also losing a lot of journalists
in the last couple years
um as the industry constraints uh and so
you're not having the same eyes you used
to have on there
these local newspapers don't have
federal court reporters
sitting at the courthouse pulling stuff
obsessive document digger
and it has brought hughes a lot of
attention with profiles on
cbs news and elsewhere hughes isn't
really even a journalist
he works at george washington
university's terror tracking section
a former u.s government official who
worked in the national counterterrorism
center
so now he's busy teaching actual
journalists how to do their jobs
better i've done about trainings for
about two thousand journalists in the
last four months
new york times washington post abc cbs
associated press basically teaching them
the tricks of the trade
it all began as hugh's work to track
young americans who have been recruited
by isis in al qaeda
he says the threat from those groups is
far from over of as much concern to
hughes
is the spike in what can be called
domestic terrorism
linked to groups overseas yeah i'm not
sure the media's really
picked up the transnational nature of of
domestic
terrorism and so it's not necessarily
domestic terrorism it's also
international
and you see these white supremacist
groups have links to organizations in
europe and
in australia and new zealand and i think
it's going to be a learning curve
in the short term there's also you have
to think of we've had you know nearly 20
years of understanding
groups like al qaeda and isis ideology
and understanding the white supremacists
and even sovereign citizen ideologies is
a different animal and so there's going
to be a learning curve
why do you do it if you give me a piece
of information and tell me
you know i've got two days to figure it
out i'm gonna roll up my sleeves
make some phone calls get on a plane and
start talking to people
because that's the only way you're gonna
figure it out well thank you so much
keep up the good work
i think it's safe to say we live in
times when the work of seamus hughes is
more important
than ever next a shout out for a team of
reporters focusing on the plight of the
people
living in america's poverty belt and the
man who has quietly made sure
they have the money to do it
we close out our special encore edition
of shout outs tonight
by honoring someone who never got a
byline never appeared in a tv report
but did much to make sure that
investigative reporting remained vibrant
especially in america's appalachian
region where tom galloway grew up
he went on to make his fortune but never
forgot where he came from
it was a project that no one news
organization had been able to take on
a sweeping indictment of how and why so
many people in america's appalachian
region
had no safe reliable source of clean
drinking water
how long did you say you've been coming
here sir reporters from
three different outlets came together
for the project from the charleston
gazette mail
my name is katie coyne i'm a reporter at
the charleston gazette mail west
virginia public broadcasting
i'm molly bourne i work with west
virginia public broadcasting
and the lexington herald leader my name
is will wright i work for the lexington
herald leader
this project especially dives into
things that affect people's daily life
you know access to water is something
that many people don't even think about
spending months traveling across west
virginia and kentucky
water should be clear and odorless
[Music]
and that's something we don't have here
and haven't for a very long time
if you turn on your tap and it's white
and it smells like chlorine you know
that's not good
it was a journalistic tour to force all
made possible by one wealthy lawyer
whose only credit was a short screen
credit at the end of the video
acknowledging the galloway foundation
chaired by tom galloway
who died earlier this year i think he
really understood poverty i think he
understood some of the really intense
struggles that happened in places like
where he grew up in appalachia
and he had a very deep sense of wanting
to give back
charlie senate runs the ground truth
project that spearheaded the water
investigation
tom understood the power of journalism
from his very earliest days as a lawyer
where he took on big coal
and really went after some of the
companies that were really
destroying the environment and treating
people very unfairly in the communities
they
where they were based as a successful
lawyer galloway was later involved in
going after the
misties at the corrupt energy company
enron
he funded projects about human rights
and lgbt rights in africa
brian ross from abc news 2020. he
followed up on the reporting that rhonda
and i did at abc news about the
treatment of garment factory workers in
sweatshops
in the american territory of the
northern marianas blocked fire exits
overheated electrical panels toilets
that don't work
what authorities called flagrant
violations of u.s
labor and safety laws part of a legal
team that later got a 20 million dollar
settlement
for some 30 000 workers
but galloway's passion was for
appalachia where he grew up in poverty
and then first emerged
as a lawyer speaking up for the little
guy tom really dedicated his entire
career to trying to
help those people who are underserved
telling their story became part of that
work
journalism became a critical appendage
to
all of the legal work that he did in a
way that
could tell a story that he wouldn't
necessarily be able to tell in the
courtroom
galloway's backing has already helped to
fund major investigations
at west virginia's leading newspaper the
gazette mail
at a time the paper was in financial
straits according to reporter
ken ward tom galloway's legacy for
appalachia
is not just all the litigation he did to
bring bad guys to justice
but it's the journalism that's going to
live on for
years and years and years giving people
the kind of information they need about
their community
we have two reporters in our newsroom
now that are funded by them and
at a time when uh advertising revenues
are dropping and
it's difficult to keep staff up uh
that kind of those kind of resources two
additional reporters one of them
dedicated to covering
southern west virginia and the other one
dedicated to covering poverty issues in
southern west virginia
galloway was once named trial lawyer of
the year by a group called public
justice
and he lived in a life of luxury with
grand homes in colorado
washington dc and martha's vineyard but
his wife kathy says
he would have traded it all to be one of
those investigative reporters
he admired so much i think he
was so enamored of the work that you
were able to do brian
and rhonda who he would have
given his left pinky to be able to
have half the talent that you had in
journalism
do you still drink your tap water or is
this solely what you drink
not really why not the water project
from ground truth came
as galloway knew his days might be
numbered
and he died knowing there were galloway
fellows across appalachia and elsewhere
doing the work he so admired he dreams
of having
a strong investigative journalism unit
in every
newspaper and radio station across
america
he was a brilliant storyteller and he
would like to see
those brilliant storytellers
telling the public what's happening in
their communities across the country but
that would
that would be a wish come true for him
tom galloway was a loyal supporter and
good friend to me and executive producer
rhonda schwartz
he'll be missed but he leaves a legacy
of investigative reporters across the
country
and around the world trying every day to
carry out the work
that tom galloway so admired that's our
report for tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you back here next week
on the law and crime network
you